♪
>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX
NEWS ALERT.
JUST MOMENTS AGO THE OFFICE
OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL,
ROBERT MUELLER, DENIED A
REPORT THAT RAN LAST NIGHT
IN BUZZFEED.
THAT STORY SAID THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD ORDERED
MICHAEL COHEN TO LIE TO
CONGRESS.
THE STORY SET OFF A FULL DAY
OF SPECULATION IN WASHINGTON
FOR MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND
THE MEDIA THAT IMPEACHMENT
AND INDICTMENT MIGHT BE
IMMINENT.
NOW, TO REPEAT, THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL IS DENYING THE
SUBSTANCE OF THAT STORY.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THIS IS MOVING VERY FAST.
A REMARKABLE DAY.
TRACE GALLAGHER HAS MORE ON
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
TRACE?
>> AND THIS REALLY IS THE
BOMBSHELL, TUCKER.
BREAKING RIGHT NOW AS YOU
SAID ROBERT MUELLER'S
SPECIAL COUNSEL, A
SPOKESPERSON, HAS KNOCKED
DOWN THIS BUZZFEED REPORT
QUOTING NOW BUZZFEED'S
DESCRIPTION OF SPECIFIC
STATEMENT TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE AND
CHARACTERIZATION OF
DOCUMENTATION AND TESTIMONY
OBTAINED BY THIS OFFICE,
REGARDING MICHAEL COHEN'S
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY ARE
NOT ACCURATE.
THAT IS CRITICAL BECAUSE,
REMEMBER, THE BUZZFEED
REPORT LAID THIS AT THE DOOR
OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
SAYING, QUOTING AGAIN, THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
LEARNED ABOUT TRUMP'S DIRECT
TIA FOR COHEN TO LIE TO
CONGRESS THROUGH INTERVIEWS
WITH MULTIPLE WITNESSES FROM
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION AND
INTERNAL COMPANY EMAILS,
TEXT MESSAGES, AND A KACH OF
OTHER DOCUMENTS.
ONE OF THE REPORTERS WHO
WROTE THE PIECE ADMITTED HE
NEVER SAW THE ALLEGED
DAMNING DOCUMENTS BUT HE
STILL MAINTAINED THAT HIS
REPORTING WAS ROCK SOLID.
LISTEN TO HIM.
>> .
I AM ROCK SOLID.
MY SOURCING ON THIS GOES
BEYOND THE TWO THAT ARE ON
THE RECORD.
IT'S 100 PERCENT PATENT.
>> 100 PERCENT EXCEPT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS IT'S
100 PERCENT DIDN'T HAPPEN
TWEETING, QUOTE:  LYING TO
REDUCE JAIL TIME, CLEARLY
REFERENCING MICHAEL COHEN'S
THREE YEAR PRISON SENTENCE.
WHITE HOUSE DEPUTY PRESS
SECRETARY HOGAN GIDLEY ADDED
THIS COMMENT.
WATCH.
>> THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
LUDICROUS THAT WE ARE GIVING
ANY TYPE OF CREDENCE OR
CREDIBILITY TO A NEWS OUTLET
LIKE BUZZFEED.
>> AND HE IS RIGHT.
BUZZFEED DOES HAVE
CREDIBILITY ISSUES,
INCLUDING MULTIPLE
ACCUSATIONS OF PLAGIARIZING
AND STEALING ORIGINAL
CONTENT.
A PEW RESEARCH SURVEY ALSO
FOUND THE PUBLICATION TO BE
UNRELIABLE AND, OF COURSE,
BUZZFEED PUBLISHED THE
UNCORROBORATED AND IS
UNCORROBORATED AND SS
UNCORROBORATED AND SALACIOUS
STEELE DOSSIER WHICH WAS
LABELED AN UNVERIFIED SMEAR
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
EVEN DEMOCRATS EAGER TO
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT HAD TO
QUALIFY THEIR COMMENTS TODAY
SAYING IF THE INFORMATION IS
TRUE.
WATCH.
>> KNOW WHETHER THE NEW
REPORT ABOUT COHEN BEING
TOLD A LIE BY THE PRESIDENT
IS TRUE OR NOT, WE'LL HAVE
TO ASK MR. COHEN THAT.
>> YEAH, COHEN IS SUPPOSED
TO GO BACK BEFORE CONGRESS
NEXT MONTH BUT HIS LEGAL
ADVISOR LANNY DAVIS SAYS HE
MIGHT BE HAVING SECOND
THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT.
REMEMBER, 24 HOURS AFTER
BUZZFEED BROKE THIS STORY,
NOBODY MATCHED THE
REPORTING.
AND NOW WE KNOW IT'S BECAUSE
IT WASN'T TRUE.
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: JUST
UNBELIEVABLE.
JUST UNBELIEVABLE.
IF YOU HAVE BEEN BY A
TELEVISION TODAY YOU HAVE
SEEN A LEVEL OF FROTHY
HYSTERIA THAT REALLY I HAVE
NEVER SEEN IN 25 YEARS OF
WATCHING.
TRACE GALLAGHER, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ANDY MCCARTHY IS A
CONTRIBUTING EDITOR AT
NATIONAL REVIEW.
HE IS THE FORMER CHIEF
ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY IN
NEW YORK, AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
ANDY MCCARTHY, THIS IS
NOT -- I THINK MOST OF US
WERE AT LEAST TAKING
SERIOUSLY THE POSSIBILITY
THAT THIS STORY WAS ROOTED
IN FACT.
NOW THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
OFFICE, WHICH HAS COMMENTED
ON VIRTUALLY NOTHING FOR THE
PAST TWO YEARS IS KNOCKING
IT DOWN.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO
THIS?
>> WELL, I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING, TUCKER, IS
THE POWER GRASP GRAB OF THE
BUZZFEED STORY IS THE ONE
TRACE GALLAGHER HONED IN ON.
AND THE REASON THAT'S
IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE WHAT
THE TRUMP RESPONSE TO THIS,
IF THERE WERE ANY
CREDIBILITY TO IT WOULD WANT
TO BE IS THAT YOU CAN'T
BELIEVE ANYTHING THAT COHEN
SAYS BECAUSE IS HE A
PERVASIVE SERIAL LIAR.
BUT THE WAY THIS STORY WAS
TEED UP, IT WAS THAT MUELLER
HAD DEVELOPED INDEPENDENT
INFORMATION.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> AND CORROBORATED IT,
PIECED IT TOGETHER HIMSELF
AND THEN HE CONFRONTED COHEN
ON IT.
NOT.
IT'S NOT A THING WHERE COHEN
IS PEDDLING THIS
INFORMATION.
IF I WERE THE WHITE HOUSE,
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
PART THAT WOULD HAVE ALARMED
ME THE MOST.
AND THAT'S THE PART THAT IT
APPEARS THAT MUELLER HAS
BLOWN UP.
I THINK THE BIG HESITATION
THAT THOSE OF US WHO WATCH
THIS SORT OF THING AND DID
THIS SORT OF WORK PROSECUTOR
WORK FOR A LIVING ALSO
COULDN'T GET OUR BRAINS
WRAPPED AROUND IS THAT WHEN
A
WHEN -- WHAT A PROSECUTOR
WOULD NORMALLY DO IF HE
THOUGHT THERE WAS A
CONSPIRACY BETWEEN TRUMP AND
COHEN TO LIE TO CONGRESS, IS
YOU WOULD HAVE COHEN PLEAD
GUILTY TO CONSPIRACY TO
OBSTRUCT A CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION AND THEN HAVE
HIM IN COURT WHEN THE JUDGE
ASKS WHAT DID YOU DO THAT
MAKES YOU GUILTY SAY I WAS
INVOLVED IN THIS CONSPIRACY
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
HE TOLD ME TO LIE TO
CONGRESS AND I WENT ON AHEAD
AND DID IT.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
>> YOU DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING
LIKE THAT IN THE CHARGES
AGAINST COHEN.
>> Tucker: SO WHERE COULD
THIS STORY HAVE COME FROM,
DO YOU THINK?
BY MY READING OF IT, AND IT
WAS PARTS OF IT WERE UNCLEAR
BY DESIGN, BUT IT LEFT THE
IMPRESSION THAT THIS WAS AN
ALLEGATION DIRECTLY FROM THE
OFFICE OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
WHERE DO YOU THINK THIS
INFORMATION CAME FROM?
>> YEAH.
THE WORD THAT STUCK OUT TO
ME, TUCKER, WHEN I READ THIS
WAS THE WORD AN ODDLY
ENOUGH.
THEY SAY AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE STORY THAT ARE THE TWO
SOURCES ARE CONNECTED TO AN
INVESTIGATION OF COHEN,
WHICH MADE IT ALLUSIVE
WHETHER THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION OF
COHEN, MEANING THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S INVESTIGATION.
SO YOU DON'T KNOW, COMING
AWAY FROM THIS ARE THESE A
COUPLE OF GUYS WHO, YOU
KNOW, ARE IN THE LOOP ENOUGH
TO GET BRIEFED ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATIONS
BUT ARE NOT IN THE CORE OF
MUELLER'S TEAM?
IT'S VERY HARD TO MAKE A
JUDGMENT ABOUT THAT.
BUT, I CAN ONLY TELL YOU
FROM, YOU KNOW, I WAS
FORTUNATE ENOUGH AS A
PROSECUTOR TO WORK ON A
COUPLE OF CASES THAT WERE
PRETTY HIGH PROFILE CASES.
AND IF YOU ASKED THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO NOW WOULD SAY
TO YOU THAT THEY WORKED ON
THOSE CASES AND WERE OF A
CASE AGENT ON THE CASE,
THERE IS PROBABLY MORE
PEOPLE THAT WOULD SAY IT
THAN WERE, YOU KNOW, THAN
SAW BOBBY THOMPSON' HOME
RUN.
THERE IS AN AWFUL LOT OF
PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE LOTS OF
INFORMATION.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
IT'S LIKE THERE WERE
50 MILLION PEOPLE WHO
CLAIMED TO HAVE BEEN AT
WOODSTOCK.
WHY WOULD THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE WEIGH IN ON
THIS TONIGHT IN THE WAY THAT
IT DID?
>> I'M REALLY PLEASED THAT
THEY DID.
I THINK THAT PROBABLY THIS
IS THE SORT OF THING THAT
COULD REALLY COMPROMISE THE
PRESIDENT'S ABILITY TO
GOVERN.
I THINK A LOT OF US WHO HAVE
BEEN TROUBLED BY THIS
INVESTIGATION FROM THE
BEGINNING THINK THAT THERE
HAS BEEN TOO MUCH DEFERENCE
TO INVESTIGATIVE SECRECY AND
NOT ENOUGH ACKNOWLEDGMENT
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE A SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATION, IT